let's take a look at one of the eight
Millennium Development Goals reducing
child mortality what's been achieved so
far since 1990 17,000 fewer children die
each day measles vaccines alone have
saved about 14 million lives but six
million children still die before their
fifth birthday each year four of every
five of those deaths are in sub-saharan
Africa and South Asia and the number of
deaths that occur during a baby's first
month after birth is on the rise overall
child mortality is decreasing worldwide
but there's still a lot that can be done
want more
download the aj+ mobile app and join the
conversation available in your App Store
now